luke and jake here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we're in the chugach
mountains of alaska and we're gonna do
some deep snow survival camping you
ready
yeah i'm a spoon
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
about five foot ten inches of snow
[Music]
all right guys it's the heart of winter
here in alaska and we're in the chugach
mountains and we are in deep deep snow
and we're going to be doing some
survival camping we don't have any tents
so we are gonna have to take a page out
of the playbook of the arctic vole a
little tiny mouse-like creature that
lives up here
and when it's winter like this
they just burrow under the snow and
that's where they live and that's how
they survive we're gonna do the exact
same thing
all right there's the ground that's the
bottom
about six feet and change
well we'll keep digging
oh
there's the blocks
go
stack it right
talk let me
[Music]
will be easy
[Music]
[Music]
can you push
so only thing
these are our building blocks
uh
[Music]
uh
uh
uh
jake are you hungry
you want a little snack
i feel that it's warm
all right there you want some cartoons
is that nice you got potato chips
cartoons and a heater
i love you i love you too buddy building
a shelter like this takes some time and
jacob's getting a little cold and hungry
and bored we gotta make sure jacob has
fun otherwise he won't go with me again
oh you might have noticed
[Music]
yes
well it's not a great roof but it'll
keep the wind off us and if we get a
little skiff of snow
shouldn't be a problem but if we get
serious snowfall this whole thing would
fall in on itself
but this will be
good enough for what i need it for the
shelter's coming along nicely but jacob
just informed me that we left his
blankie back at the car
so we're gonna hike all the way back to
the car to go get his blankie
that's what we do
well operation blinky was a success and
we're back at the campsite i think i
need to get the sleeping bags busted out
and get things a little cozier
because i got a boy who's winding down
all right
get it into the shelter
along with your sleeping bag we got two
caribou hides and these will add some
insulation and also protect our air mats
from being popped
[Music]
well there we go that's our bed for
tonight
not much to look at but it'll keep us
out of the wind
that's got to be cold
here
i'll put hand warmers inside here
when you build these shelters you want
to make them in a zigzag s pattern so
the wind never can have a straight shot
into your sleeping area it helps a lot
the wind's picked up a little bit we got
about 5 10 mile per hour wind which
doesn't sound like a lot
but when it's cold man it makes a
difference
wearing snowshoes isn't just about
staying on top of the snow when you
stomp down the snow with the snowshoes
you can usually come back over the top
of it and walk normally without snow
shoes
when i was a kid we used to do a lot of
winter camping and we would dig proper
snow caves where we dig tunnels under
the snow and sleep in them like gophers
but it takes a lot of snow to get away
with that and it has to be the right
kind of snow it has to be compressed
frozen snow not light fluffy stuff and
this stuff is about
24 30 inches of light fluffy stuff then
there's a good solid band of crunchy
stuff right there 10 more inches of
fluffy stuff and then you don't really
have the good solid compressed ice until
about like right here so if i were to
cut
the tunnel like this i'd only have about
that much before we get to all the
flimsy stuff probably wouldn't collapse
on me but it'd be a bit sketchy so i'm
not gonna fuss with it really the only
reason to dig a proper snow cave versus
a trench like this is when it's really
cold i'm talking deep in the negatives
you can get in a snow cave and you'll
always be about 15 degrees 20 degrees no
matter how cold it gets outside it'll
never be warm in a snow cave but
it won't get crazy cold like negative 20
or so if you build it right but tonight
it's only supposed to get down to like
six or ten degrees fahrenheit so we just
need something to keep the wind off
i got a white gas cam stove here that i
use in the winter time because the
isobutane stoves don't work well in the
extreme cold plus these things are
really slick this one made by msr
it'll work off of unleaded fuel white
gas
kerosene lots of different things you
can put in here so if you're traveling
abroad or going to remote places you can
get fuel really easy
there you go
you go
lentil and veggie tikka masala
i found this at a camping store it's a
pizza apparently you just add some water
into the packaging and it starts a
chemical reaction that heats it up so
you can have hot pizza with just water
so uh we're gonna give this a try
here's the heater here's the pizza
pizzas go back in here
water's really cold i hope this works
okay put this in here
curious to see if it can work in these
cold temperatures we got another one
that's chickpea masala so we're gonna
try that one out too
okay
seal that up see what that does oh there
we go got some steam coming out
feels warm oh it's nice on the hands
let's see is it
that kind of looks like pizza but it's
warm here
[Music]
little bit of difference between the
image on the package and uh what we got
well that's not the best pizza in the
world but uh it's warm
there we go lentil and chickpea tikka
masala that looks so good careful it's
real hot
the pizza makes a half decent stand-in
for naan
oh i'm so hungry
i'm usually not a fan of lentil and
chickpea curries but oh this is hitting
the spot
oh you gotta eat so quick your food goes
from hot to ice cold in an instant
all right you get down and just even
back burrow down in there man it is cold
the temperature is just
dropping like crazy
i'm gonna have some seconds here
i'm hungry
make sure that lid is on there good okay
got this thermos full of boiling hot
water here
i'm gonna put that thermos of hot water
inside my sleeping bag and
preheat the bag
it is cold out here i got a second
bottle here i'm gonna fill that up with
hot water too make sure jacob's got one
as well
are you warm enough do you want some
more heater down there
you're hot you're too hot
okay well i'll tell you one problem with
camping in deep snow is it's really hard
to find firewood unless you've got
standing dead wood you just you're not
gonna find it and there's not a lot of
standing dead wood around here
and i really wanted to sit by a campfire
so i kind of i kind of brought something
just to just so we could do that a
little bit
i just got myself a number 10 tin can
with a little bit of wire around it and
you know these little logs you can buy
for the fireplace if you don't want to
build a proper fire well i got like half
of one of those
all right
oh that feels nice on the hands
my fingers have been so cold on this
trip this little chunk right here will
last about two hours so between that and
this i've got about four to six hours
worth of campfire right there
the temperature is dropping out here it
is cold i'm gonna bust out my
thermometer and see what temperature we
got
all right thermometer says zero degrees
fahrenheit
i'll tell you what the wind is
absolutely howling down in the valley
it's wind chill is below negative 15.
but we're really sheltered where we're
at we're right up against a hill and
next to some trees and then once you get
down below the the snow line
it's uh nice and still in here so you're
not you don't have that wind chill to
deal with
all right we're going to take the
thermometer down here see what the
temperature is at our bags
we can see down here by the sleeping
bags we've got about 16 degrees
fahrenheit so definitely cold but a lot
warmer than it is above the trench
and that's the beauty of snow caves if
you build them right they're always
about 16 15 degrees fahrenheit no matter
what the weather is like outside i'll
tell you what i haven't heard a peep out
of jacob
i think he's falling asleep inside a
sleeping bag i think i'll just let him
let him rest i put some hand warmers on
him and offered to put a hot water
bottle in his sleeping bag and he
refused it and took the hand warmers off
he said he was too hot those sleeping
bags are really nice i got them from
feathered friends in seattle and they'll
customize the length for free and so i
had them get one of their negative 25
women's bags and shorten it down so it's
perfect for tommy and nate and jake
it's just absolutely awesome bag
well it's getting late and sitting here
on the snow is getting me cold i'm gonna
get in my sleeping bag
oh i got a set of down slippers i'm
gonna put on
all right guys i'm getting to bed and i
set up a time lapse for you so enjoy
that i'll see you in the morning
[Music]
good morning oh my goodness we slept in
so long look the sun's up
it's about nine in the morning and i'm
still in my sleeping bag partially it's
because i'm tired and partially because
it's really really warm in here i don't
want to get out
biggest downside to this kind of cabbie
is that you've got no warm fire to look
forward to
oh
there's my pants they're nice and
covered in snow
but i get up and get some oatmeal made
time to suck it up
it's about nine degrees
it's nippy
oh hey jake you awake hey good morning
you sit there and rest i'll get some
breakfast made okay
[Music]
well there's a little ice shelter right
there and you can see why it was
sheltered from the wind last night got
that little hill right there against the
back and the trees but it was blowing
out here
blowing out here really hard the trail
we made is pretty
pretty frozen up nice and solid
[Applause]
all right let's see about getting some
oatmeal cooked got a bottle of water
that's not frozen
got some sausages here
but they're a little frozen
[Applause]
that sausage hits the
spot jake do you want a sausage
don't get your bag dirty
my honey's frozen
i'll tell you what when you go winter
camping don't bring metal cups bowls or
silverware use plastic the metal gets so
cold your fingers just get like frost by
touching it so bad
this just looks so good
that warms you up
gotta stand up kneeling down that ice
just makes my body so cold
i really should have brought like a
little backpacking chair or something
but you know whatever it's a point of
camping right having fun doing without
yeah now i need to get this mess cleaned
up
ah that's where my spoon went
whenever you're sleeping in these snow
caves or in these trenches put as many
insulators between you and the ground as
possible reindeer pelts foam mat air mat
cardboard pine bow anything you can do
just don't lay on the ground without a
good insulator you will freeze
it always amazes me how empty the sled
is when i'm coming in and how full it is
when i'm coming out
if i just throw everything in the sled
thanks for watching guys we hope you
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more adventures from the outdoor boys
youtube channel don't forget to click
subscribe because we put out new videos
every saturday morning thanks for
watching guys i'll see you next saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]